hello went welcome to this video which
covers the ninth round of the candidates
tournament currently held in Moscow
yeah the ninth round means we are
nearing the finishing line every game
it's getting in some way more important
yeah I mean it's the same kind of same
kind of point that you can earn on round
one but still as it gets closer to the
finishing line things get get tighter
and get more more tense let's see what
happened in this round I'm sorry with
the game Nakamura kayaking which means
pairing between a player who's not
really in contention anymore Nakamura is
too far behind with being on - to having
lost three games already and kayaking
was yet um yes unbeaten yeah he was in
trouble in a couple of games but still
unbeaten and it's with the plus a two
score among the leaders let's see what
happened in this game almost gets the
opening this is the Queen's Indian
tournament got this - so often yeah it's
quite funny we get the line that we had
seen a lot in the earlier rounds this
position here after rugby one actually
was on the board in the game between
wasn't too far off I really look that up
so part of K I cannot believe right hmm
what to talk nonsense eh but I think
it's to pile of kayak and we had this
earlier the idea is to play before in
this position and trying to make the
move c5 yeah a little bit less
attractive for black in this earlier
game kayaking had played c5 and after th
stakes we had the position with 95 that
got very tense but I think top olive
probably had an interesting attacking
possibility there
night pd7 it's now played by a kayak and
it's funny the coming variation the
coming line with B for Bishop c4 as
apparently had been suggested in notes
to that earlier game by maxima Sheila
Graf was covering some of them
candidates tournaments games on chess
calm in a blog or as part of their
coverage MV Ellis their staff
commentator and he had given this line
here Bishop f4 94 and takes takes 92
bishop takes a two funny--i why does
giving away this is pawn on a two but it
has a funny 420 point interesting point
Bishop takes e4 very interesting the
rook is attacked but it's also white
sockets under fire after Bishop be one
Queen be one white is happy to sacrifice
his exchange here black should not save
the rook he can't play rugby a them just
just to show what happens but white will
catch on age 7 and go back and he enjoys
the fantastic compensations between
formed the exchange he's got a pawn
blacks King position is is bad White has
got two very good bishops and great
central control here there's also the
ongoing idea of playing something like
b5 which would make both those two pawns
look pretty bad also note that the rooks
currently don't have any scope this
position is excellent for white so kayak
and played Knight to f6 and decided to
give back the exchange immediately this
is what happened and now
efore was played and a camera grabbed
this central space he played this rather
quickly the whole sequence but now kayak
he came up with rook e8 and it seems
that he he was
sometime they're not blitzing out the
moose yeah after this move things are
not so easy for white this pawn is under
fire and how do you react here a
possibility here is to move look to see
one attacking c7
but after Ruka d4 Lukas e7 it doesn't
really lead to that much yeah black can
play Bishop dat if he likes or route e7
rook d7 no ever allows this interesting
possibility which at least get some
material imbalance yeah
after after a rogue wolf yeah black like
this for example it's an interesting
position black can also play this looks
a bit strange but he can also return
this and and have a good position here
the whole thing looks ok for black I
think Bishop e3 was played by nakamura
after long thought and now Knight g4
this was the problem with Bishop III but
you had to cover the pawn somehow yeah
h3 and Anton captured white had to allow
this somewhat broken pawn structure but
at least he has some pawns in the center
that control important squares yeah I
think I Aki now play said well he plays
the move 85 this is strong
yeah right now only has some options or
has move said don't really feel that
great but he doesn't have anything
better
if he goes b5 he has to worry about the
a pawn and after the capture black
screen gets activated
this was the bearable for clearing
between 85 and now Queen c2 happened and
25 yeah rook f3 + c5 yeah the situation
is a bit uncomfortable for YTM
after Queen b3 now played by nakamura i
think i akan could have improved on his
play he took on d4 the ignoring this
threat on f7 after that I think the
position is probably equal it looks very
tactical but it kind of fizzles out
strong would have been probably quit to
age five in this position covering and
attacking at the same time okay you
cannot easily take on a shreemant it's
it's under fire this pawn and I don't
really know what white should do here
nothing looks totally satisfactory he
can go with d5 yeah black was
threatening to take that pawn so d5 and
then it would be eight intending to play
c5 and this doesn't look it doesn't look
great I think black is is quite
comfortable here for example after a
simple move which probably isn't so
great
kingi - there's b5 and those pawns are
dangerous while the center is not going
anywhere why it's not lost it's
complicated but I think black has the
better chances him
yeh played this a technical solution but
this ultimately doesn't net much but
only because Nakamura plays yeah a
sequence of very precise defensive moves
h4 Queen e5 and now Knight c4 that he
all he had to calculate all that and
perfectly Queen takes rook f4 and also
again strong looking at this attacking
the Queen of course and chance now is
forced now black has to watch out this
is hanging and there's potential trouble
on the back rank yeah he went with rook
e8 giving up this bishop and well he
gets the knight back but this is yeah
understandable standard
yeah it looks really it looks a bit
dangerous and 9 f7 would be made but
white doesn't get any tricks and say ya
know the knife gets eliminated and B
pawn and a pawn are just as dangerous
and for either side fast forward a
little bit here they agree to a draw
after just 3 d3
it's totally equal yeah a good fighting
game between the two Nakamura's opening
idea with this offering the exchange
Chang we should maybe have a look
briefly at this again here offering the
exchange was answered very convincingly
by Kuryakin not taking the or not taking
the exchange but returning it
immediately or let's say keeping not
keeping the exchange but returning it
immediately instead of letting white
capture on h7 so good defense but
kayaking which is anyway his his best
trade yeah he's a fantastic defender he
saved a couple of really bad positions
already in the tournament a couple
assists too much but then he could have
lost against Sweden for example and
wasn't trouble in one more game okay so
next game we look at tu parles wiggler
also again two players who will not be
involved in the in the top places to par
love is currently last in the event and
villa yeah has a tournament of spoiled
opportunity as he could have won against
Kuryakin could have warned against
karana but he didn't do it and he could
have easily been on a plastic or okay
this game is actually a little bit more
complicated than I probably make it look
like North analysis but I don't want to
via be too detailed I have a little bit
of a time restraint today we have a room
and Sweden is not a Berlin player he
plays the only main line with a six and
placed castles again as he did earlier
in the event against Vichy a game that
he lost him quite convincingly very nice
game by about honored and I'm a bit
surprised that he plays it again I mean
not that this is bad it's the Marshall
attack move order you just said Sevilla
also has a great history of playing the
close Droid which starts here where he
most of the time plays the side self but
he also has played the brea yeah I would
have expected him to maybe return to
that but okay it seems that he has
prepared the Marshall and so castles and
okay
he gets the a for anti Marshall again
and now switches to before he played
Bishop e7 against honored but before in
the last couple of years has become the
main line so no big surprise there
um and III yeah not a surprise that
would be too much but in recent years
they have experimented a lot with d4
which ultimately didn't lead to much but
still it was discussed a lot okay III
and h6
yeah black has a couple of options how
to play him another option is to go for
a quick and Knight a5 for example
something like this like it is six not
VD to Knight a5 this is also something
that we see quite often it I think it's
quite reliable I am NOT a huge expert
here because I play the close threw away
all the time don't play the Marshall so
I cannot get this position in my own
games
yeah sweetener plays a little bit
differently
it starts with age six and here plays
with rook to b8
I'm not entirely sure about this whole
concept I mean it looks kind of normal
as you quite often play in those with
lines but it's quite clear that Sweden
got into some trouble out of the opening
so age three and no not yet but we will
see you deform
yeah and now Bishop f8 you know the
situation on the Queen side is what
makes this different compared to some
other Budapest lines quite often you
would see this rookie aid bishop a vain
and so on but black then does not we
don't have this situation on the Queen
side and it seems that the coming
operation that Svidler goes for which is
not untypical it does not lead to a
satisfactory position he clarifies the
situation in the center and plays Knight
to before yeah the idea is that the
knight on c6 is not well placed and by
moving it you get this addition to play
c5 and d5 possibly if if you can get it
in even both most try to get active in
the center and try to fight the white
pawn Center the drawback of all this is
it doesn't seem to quite work I mean
it's close but it doesn't seem to quite
work to part of plays Bishop a3 and now
whatever black does it is a little bit
it's a little bit awkward it's a little
bit awkward yeah black cannot go here I
mean it doesn't make any sense what I'm
trying to say after rook e3 the knight
has to has to return so
what is the alternative Spiller plate
the move d5 in this position but that
didn't really didn't really work yeah it
got him into trouble at least he could
play c5 this is an interesting option
but after he five it feels very
dangerous for black like nineteen 594
somehow this didn't really work out for
him and after d5 two Paul Offit the
strongest Knight to e5 and the problem
is you always have this annoying
pressure here on f7 and it's very hard
for black to deal with that sweeter
played Bishop e7 and now Queen f3 again
lining up against f7 currently there's a
knight on f6 but there is a tactic
available that we would see very quickly
this is not like a winning sacrifice or
anything but the thing is after King
takes is forced if five white will get
this back and the remaining structure or
the resulting structure is just very
nice for white black has to get his King
out of this and now after after these
trades the position is just very nice
for white he actually had alternatives
along the way but this is a nice
position
this is hanging this is somewhat
backward and a black is under pressure
he played survive this is the best best
chance you need to be active you cannot
just stay and be passive so that's the
best defense
neither three and rook to be 895 looks
normally and centralizes and this got
traded Bishop d6 and now Bishop b2 yeah
white has the more active position and
this is a pretty bad piece also note
that black constantly has to worry with
this diagonally
yeah this is a tough decision but he
needed to probably get rid of this yeah
it was it was tough to and play with the
Queens on the board even though this
position now is clearly favorable for
white due to them due to the bishop pair
rook b5 try to at least attack this pawn
and a Bishop t1 not the only move but I
think what the polyp is doing here is
totally fine he just here has to improve
after Bishop c6 he now played the move
Bishop c2 and after that black is
somehow back in the game if he would
have played Bishop a4 I think he would
have been very very close to winning the
game
yeah what is black supposed to do the
relatively best is route before you have
group before and counter-attacking
yeah what is about doing just grabbing
this of course rook takes and now look
to the 1 and this is very very awkward
now this position is a lot better for
white who is just threatening to grab
this pawn and like it's sitting in this
very awkward pin yeah this is not
helping fancy tricky but it doesn't help
chang-chang know this gets lost yeah and
what is Plex supposed to play I mean he
can play a King move but why it just
goes here and we'll again with one of
the pawns white is probably winning if
not would be very very weird I mean it
this must be very close to win okay this
is what he played however and now after
Knight f4 black is quite surprisingly
close to consolidating one important
point is that here he gets to activate
with tempo and his bishop comes to b5
where this all of a sudden anchored
yeah it's nicely protected by this
and can go here to protect d5 so all of
the Sun blacks pieces have some
coordination why it still is probably
quite happy with these bishops but they
are not as important here anymore as the
black position is much better
coordinated yeah of course to part of
continued young he still has this
symbolic advantage but the worst is
definitely over from black Jay Jay yeah
here they agreed to a draw
actually I think he could have tried to
continue the play of Lytton degree third
row why is that
finished yeah that's funny me I'm sorry
no I this is this is my screw-up I was
actually thinking yeah I'm okay I'm
sorry
and they agreed to draw here but I
wasn't quite sure why actually because
after King g6 to pull off could have
still tried to move age for trying to
play age five and there is no it's not
totally clear why white needs to agree
to a draw here when he he offered the
draw but why he should stop trying to
play for a win I mean I'm not saying why
does a lot better here but you could
continue him I don't know maybe the part
of didn't judge that correctly and he's
pretty fed up with the whole thing it's
it's possible I mean even he's on minus
three he had to he has to win like the
rest of his games to get get some well I
mean okay if he really what with him the
rest of the games he would probably
qualify but it doesn't feel realistic at
all okay
the next game to check is some is yes
what am I doing here my notes a mess is
again Geary Caruana so what is the
starting point for that game Geary is on
50% eight draws and Corona has scored a
win against
Nakamura so is sitting pretty okay with
this plus one score he's definitely in
contention
so Giri has to make a move and I mean
not just a move move on the on the board
he has to also get something going you
know you need to win game so aha
first of all I think it's great that
kawana is not playing something super
solid he seems to be out for the Grune
felt and give a place f3 this is not
part of his regular repertoire I mean he
plays that sometimes but it's not a
regular feature of his of his openings
and this is probably one of the sharpest
lines that you can play the idea is that
after the typical good firm move that
was played why'd we go in for and black
here has nothing to take on c3 so yes to
go back to b6 and here quite often we
see extremely sharp play with white
going for long castles and this is
exactly what Geary it needs to do here
he has to win a game and I really love
his openly Joycean and not yeah playing
something something cautious whatever he
has to win a game at one point and this
is hopefully work obviously what he
wants to try him and black has a couple
of options he can play knight c6 for
example or I think even the move Queen
d6 has been tried I hope I'm not talking
nonsense yeah but what koala plays is a
traditional line that has been played
yep even back in the making the 90s he 5
attacking the center directly and now
going c6 ya age 4
this is what white needs to do here you
cannot play ya subtle positional chess a
you want to checkmate on the edge farm
and take stakes and h5 the move Knight a
6 is a rare a rare move
the far more common option him instead
should show that briefly is rook a to d7
the idea usually being that the night
comes over to have six to put more
pressure on that pawn this was for
example played in the island gelfand
match in 2012 and that is six this has a
very very sharp idea age five night
before H takes g6 and now the shocking
move Bishop to f5 yeah this is this is
really amazing
what karana is playing here it's
obviously part of his preparation played
this quite quickly but give me a head to
invest some time to figure things out
yeah the black is just ignoring this age
flag of 86 and goes for play on c2 okay
Chang white took this and King h8 of
course yeah what about this Knight c2 is
the threat yeah this move looks fairly
logical stepping out of this fork and
supporting the D pawn yeah black now
checked went nazi to check and grabbed
only three of this position yeah it
seems that this was a yeah part of
Nirvana's preparation and this is a
pretty amazing concept and if we if we
just do a simple counting Black has
given up two pawns for this position and
to be honest I don't quite believe it
works but yeah it is sir it is a pretty
amazing concept he now plays the move
Bishop to d7 this is played in order to
get the F pawn involved into the into
the game black had alternatives he could
have played and rooks
for example but this is obviously what
he what he wanted to do Bishop to d7
trying to play a5 problem is however
after 9h 3 & 5 and now f4 it's not
totally clear how black is supposed to
open up the position against the white
king this is what he actually tried he
tried to open everything up as much as
possible but I'm not quite sure it it
works so well the computer stoppers in
that case wants to play the most afore
and after 95 rook c8 pretty amazing it
and the computer just gives white a
slight advantage in this position so
black definitely has some compensation
here it's however pretty tough for me to
believe that it is enough for two pawns
however you should never underestimate
the practical side to play this position
it's not easy at all to suggest some
clear idea for white here you know it's
two pawns but the H pawn on age 7 well
it's kind of limiting blacks King but
it's also something that can easily yeah
drop if you remove your pieces away and
the D pawn looks nice but currently is
nowhere near promotion it's very very
tough to judge he played rook c8 and
after g3 again had this opportunity to
play before and it seems that this is
what he should do the the issue is white
is now ready to take this pawn and this
is what Kawana simply ignored with his
move and it doesn't seem to ya just
quite work
he plays Knight C for him yeah Geary has
to take this and now takes
only five now what is three pawns up but
that wasn't the end of it the idea was
to play f4 yeah pretty cool yeah white
no hesitate with the night taking with
the pawn after Bishop takes root eggs
yeah but this probably takes looks very
dangerous for white it is a lot stronger
to take with the night
yeah note that white is for pawns up for
okay
Queen g5 backronym the white king is of
course not feeling too well them but
still it's four pawns this is not the
four pawn attacking this is a four point
a gambit and absolutely absolutely wild
position yeah give me now place route to
d4 and this returns upon and it's a very
understandable uniformity and it was
played in the face of a black idea if
white is not you are paying attention
which it sounds very really position
like that black might sacrifice on f4 I
mean you move like a three for example
black will take here check check check
King back and then check stuff like that
okay yeah this is winning for black
white has to pay attention to that idea
both sacrifice actually what would work
and the best move was not played by
giving very very difficult to play this
position it seems that instead of giving
the back pawn with rook to e4 he had to
move keen to e1 and that seems to be
very strong
it's a typical computer move the
computer has absolutely cold-blooded and
just moves the King back into it
starting square so what are the ideas
here if black well stop the easy ones
this is me
wait but Bishop takes is all shy not
great because of this shy
yeah and white is some is managing to
yeah to kill off the attack and he's
still got three parts them so the e5
pawn is its taboo cannot be taken yeah
so what is blacksmith actually the
problem is that white also has the idea
route to h5 if black tries this for
example trying to take here then Luke h5
is hitting and this is pretty awful the
relatively best that black can try is
this but after Knight takes rook takes
and something like this wide yeah
retains a winning position yeah it's
simply too many pawns if we had look at
this yeah here it's it's three pawns and
black some black is also under direct
threats like rookie 7 this is not a
position that then black can can fight
or so sometimes you can find yeah with
two bishops against two knights you have
some fighting ideas we won't see that
later in the game but here black simply
has no moves I mean what is he supposed
to play rugby 7s the threat yes we
cannot take this for example
yeah after King e1 it seems that here
black does not have a good move that
drew h5 is a threat and of course if
things kind of dry out then white is
just winning with four pawns
so this was probably a way to to win the
game
right here it's still I mean it's a
super messy position so you cannot say
for sure that this would have won but
it's objectively speaking this is
probably the case rook T for
understandable move yeah trades and
trade one look and give one pawn back to
ya to kind of calm down blacks blacks
initiative but it's now back down to
three pawns it's not for you or just
free okay
Giri set up a defensive information here
trying to coordinate the other look is
coming here but black is holding on
note that okay pure body count is three
pawns but it's absolutely not easy for
white to get get to yeah get to play
some constructive play the Jeep on
cannot easily move as it needs to be
there to anchor this night the deep horn
is is under under control and how are
you actually going to do something it is
remarkably difficult it's reports but
very difficult to win however in this
precise position probably there is an
improvement Giri went Queen to d2 and
stepping out of the ephah it seems that
rook h5 again was a was a good move
again I mean we had this in an earlier
in earlier line the idea is that black
has some issues now with finding a
useful move what is he supposed to play
if yeah for example what is what is an
idea let's say he I am this is not
working you to boogie 5j you know
deciding immediately yeah black is
somewhat limited in his choices if he
plays Bishop d6 we managed to trade
Queens yeah I mean this is not helping
difficult for black to just to move the
engine wants to take but this is
something that black is quite reluctant
to do we are getting into some self pin
after King g1 I think white is quite
happy that black went into this like
this
tending a queen up could be tricky for
black is still not easy winning or so
but it's probably a bit more testing
than Gary's if he went back and black
I'm sorry it is success needs to be here
black is reasonably active again
rooks see to all of the Sun becomes an
option yeah I mean it looks a bit weird
that white is kind of giving back over
the pawns but how do you how do you
continue against this pressure yeah we
played this in order to gain the d5
square yeah I really understand his play
I mean he's still two pawns up but it
kind of it's not a it's not a great
trend yeah if you've been on Plus for
poor pawns yeah not plus for valuation
but it way it's been four points now
it's just two and G and H pawn are not
looking get dangerous immediately but it
wasn't immensely immensely difficult
position to play and note that Kawana is
defending like a lion yeah this is
really something to say take note of
this tournament shows how strong
nowadays the defensive capabilities are
of the top players they absolutely don't
lose vers positions automatically now
they very very quickly recognize oh I'm
in trouble I have to now give 120 130
percent and give everything to defend
and really really bad positions have
been saved in this tournament
not because of yeah bad technical play
some cases this has this has happened
but also because of fantastic defensive
evidence yeah Kawana is just hanging on
here in this position check yeah he just
has gotten the next pawn back Chang
Chang yes I would wide thought check up
checks out well here now he gets this
night in yeah and a text now with two
knights this was Jewish ideas
retains the pawn but now gets his
knights activated yeah I have to say
that this game from here is still going
on for more than 50 moves and I don't
intend to commentate on them white is
basically getting nowhere which does not
mean that this was easy to play Sherlock
yeah he still had to be absolutely a
suit look at all the tricks and nice
jumps and whatever but Quran is simply
not breaking down there wasn't a single
opportunity from here
where he could have won the game and
tried really everything check no way to
enjoy it against bishop check check
check
Jaime yeah Oh to betray me
check check check check
it's the longest games at the event
check check check check
yeah yeah yeah here they agreed to draw
and there's nothing nothing going on if
white is not checking then he will face
Bishop c4 with counter play against
against the king yeah a great defensive
effort by Kawana I think what happened
here is he prepared the super sharp
opening and then had a really really a
weak moment when he decided on that
night see for business when he was those
four pawns down I mean it's it looks
interesting definitely it's not like it
looks totally nonsensical but its its
form it's four pawns and King one seems
to have yeah probably leading leads to a
decisive one advantage the game odds
there was no fun yeah defending 498
moves or something in this in this
position material down but ultimately he
managed and he stays on the plus one
squad that gives him all the chances
to qualify for the design match against
Carlton um but we also have to give
credit to Giri here who finally played a
yeah full-fledged
attacking game and got a winning
position but it yeah it just happens
sometimes yeah but you have to get into
this these positions first so very good
very good stuff here by the Dutch player
okay final game in this recap is Anand
aronia so we have our not was on +1
definitely in contention playing against
the tournament leader Aronian was on +2
so Vichy is going for the Italian game
and we have them what we would probably
can call that the current main line here
with a four this has really gained
momentum in in recent recent month this
a four idea to develop the night to a
three and yeah this for example this
precise position was on the board in a
game Giri are not the worst kind of snot
diverse colors but honored on the black
side in in Zurich yeah so night a three
years once idea and here displayed
aronia now technically plays the novelty
which shows that this position is
relatively new because the actual move
is totally normal
he plays Knight to g7 going over to g6 a
very common idea in the in the in the
Italian game the knight on c6 was mostly
looking at protected square so in the
groups
so all this looks rather normal and we
should be three castles yeah usually the
black is reluctant in those structures
to trade only three here it probably is
because he doesn't want to give white
and easy recapture
some other other lines white would take
with the F pawn and open up this it
doesn't make much sense here with the
knight being on c2 but this is often a
motivation for black not to take on e3
and give white adoptions of ok castles
and taken on a seven-night g3 and yeah I
think this is all looking very very
standard and then the next move by
Aronian i have to admit i don't like
that much he plays Knight to g4 and I
mean I don't think that this is the
reason for his troubles but I'm not sure
that this helps let's say the knight on
f6 has one particular positive feature
it always looks at this pawn and makes
it a little bit more difficult for a
white to play the move d4 and I think I
would probably prefer here - yeah -
maybe not correct the rook or so
yeah delay any decision what to do here
on the Kings side and ask white what he
is going to play yeah keep an eye on
that pawn so there D form doesn't help
after Knight reform why it is rather
quick here with this deform oh I'm also
not so sure about a 5 but I have to say
that the subtleties of those positions
are really difficult to grasp do you
want to play a 5 here or not white
sometimes gets this in and has yeah a
good space gain but I'm really not sure
if it is worth to spend immense to play
a 5 I really I cannot tell you what what
I know is that the resulting position
now after deform and hook' 8 is
surprisingly a little bit difficult for
black to handle a lot now took on e5
that looks very that looks a bit
simplistic but it is not bad at all the
interesting point is that the normal
recaptured detail
is actually pretty bad yeah and now
black is in some trouble and he has to
play this awkward move and now look t1
and it's very difficult now to even get
the bishop out somewhere and that that
is not a good position at all
so he couldn't do that he had to take
with the night and I takes and again if
you take with the pawn this is not so
easy takes takes and yeah ruku t1 and
this night is very well positioned the
black Bishop doesn't have a good square
I mean yeah something like this is
probably yeah not not a pneumonia set up
white can we have for example gain space
with before it doesn't look very
comfortable he decided to take with the
night but here in this in this position
I think Black has not equalized
completely White has more space and it's
definitely easier for white to plane
yeah ok this now was played I probably
would have prefered there should be six
but ok 97 now b6 yeah this is the kind
of move that you you actually don't like
to play with black the problem of it is
that it's somehow weakens the light
squares a lot and yeah hindsight is
20/20 we will see what happens in the
game there probably it's not that bad
but you know we get used to be slowly
drift into something that looks
absolutely not great for black mhmm
black has no space and he cannot prevent
a piece from coming to d5 c6 is simply
not not possible it's just a pretty
passive position
and this is not fun this is not fun
Black is sitting there very passively
and how would you ever get that book
only seven into the game yeah I mean
ultimately or not ultimately he
relatively quickly decided that you have
to take on d5 and well it's not
something that you love to do allow the
c-pawn capture and then you're sitting
there with that pawn on c7 but it's very
difficult to avoid it in the long run
yeah Huronia tries to defend by check by
simplification 1937 and f6 just block it
completely trying to block it but of
course why it has lots of more space and
now gets to work on the kingside yeah
tough decision but at the end you cannot
play without the rookie or the whole
game so he decided to take on d5 and get
this back okay King of three and rook to
e8 yeah
very interesting position now I not now
decided to immediately go for it and he
got rewarded quite quickly for that
decision um here of course white also
could opt for further yeah further
improvements playing very slowly that
would have been an option looks like a
g4 or something like that you can play
energy for us probably not a great idea
but you can try to improve slowly here
I'm not however decided to do something
directly rookie to g4 threatening King
f5 and this is something that black
cannot allow if white gets the stinger
up to f5 just invading this is this is
not acceptable
so black now has no choice he has to
grab that pole
for and he did say Rupa g7 check yeah
and it seems that to the next smooth
gets black into into a real trouble I
mean he had a bad position in passive
position but not necessarily a losing
position and after the next move which
looks I mean perfectly normal it
probably is it's almost indefensible he
played this and yeah it seems that King
d8 was better it's very difficult to
figure the differences out but one key
point is said after King d8 if white
tries to now play s in the game
Luke D to C to a key difference is that
here after this and Roxy to black has
defensive ideas in f5 and rookie file F
is the the cleanest way probably King
takes shank f8 is enough counter play or
here then Ruby 7 note that for example
this is only possible because the king
is here not on c8 in the game he played
King to see it it looks completely
normal and this kind of decision if it
is taken with no time it's very
difficult you just quite often just base
it on intuition and sometimes this is
the wrong decision
rook t2 and here is the second key point
maybe now black should probably take
that a for pawn after this and this he
has c5 which looks yeah it looks
questionable or it looks I don't know
tricky but this is the key move that
gives black counter plane that also
seemed to be playable it's still
critical for black but it's probably
better than the game this was played in
the game King b8 that was more 14 and
now
and the position becomes probably close
to being lost I don't really see how to
improve now for black c7 is is attacked
and the active defenses don't seem to
work he played this ultimately yeah if
you take here cc7 should be probably
winning for white the the big difference
is simply that White's King is active
and will take will take pawns and this
is just participating while black is
sitting there with this passive King on
b8 it's a bit tough to analyze this no
till till the end let's save it it's
also very very critical and black yeah
ookay - looks a bit passive but white
wants to play this try and win this pawn
which is more important now he's got
three against one on the Kings side and
the Queen side is just not mobile at all
Jay Jay Jay and this is the same picture
those pawns will come forward quickly
and they are supported by the king and
black doesn't have any adequate counter
play yeah here
rooks e2 didn't help I wouldn't have
helped it has to block it and now the
pot pawn some Jay start rolling yeah
okay a3 wasn't necessary but it wins the
Jeep on is too strong Jay Jay yeah this
jack up to 5 after a king move why just
takes the rook and wins with the rook up
so if we need for honored yeah a super
important results for this event means
that anna joins the lead with +2
together with Karen and Aronian gets
back to a +1 score not the end of the
world is Celeste all on chances but yeah
B she is in contention very very clearly
and as was predicted by some some people
I mean Boris Gelfand for example
predicted that Vichy will win this event
which I found well not a very likely
prediction but yeah he proves us all
wrong by again being completely yeah
being being in the thick of things yeah
he's currently leading with event
together with kayaking
one thing that should be noted is that
if two players finish on the same score
in this tournament the direct result
will determine the player who will
challenge card so that means for example
in the current situation Anna and
kayaking they are on the same number of
points if they would finish like that
those two players then it would be they
would be to check what those two players
played against each other and kayaking
be honored so this is a very important
fact so let's say V she would draw
kayaking in their upcoming game and they
would escort the same points then
kayaking would qualify so kayaking has
pretty good pretty good
situation there in case of a tie break
okay I hope you enjoyed the coverage of
round 9 yeah we still have five rounds
left and it will only get more exciting
thanks for watching